à l'occasion du salon mondial de la
sécurité intérieure milipol qui se tient
à paris depuis le début de la semaine
faisons un point sur l'utilisation par
les forces de l'ordre du taser ce
pistolet non létale sans feu immobilisé
à un individu dangereux
la ministre de l'intérieur michèle
alliot marie annoncent la création d'un
groupe de travail qui devra réfléchir
aux conditions d'utilisation du taser
larmes n'est pour le moment pas autorisé
mais plusieurs municipalités voudrait en
équipe et leur police nathalie perez
sybille greenberg
voici le taser x26 une arme futuriste
qui ressemble à un gadget mais qui est
capable à l'aide de deux électrodes
reliées à un fil en métal de projeter
cinquante mille volts sur sa cible
en voici les effets dans la réalité ce
détenu violent refuse d'être extrait de
sa cellule
le taser le fait à nice 5 à 6 secondes
le temps suffisant pour le neutraliser
autre situation face à un molosse le
collègue de ce policier américain
attaqué va faire usage de son taser
quelques secondes plus tard le chien
s'enfuit dans la direction opposée en
france policiers gendarmes doivent
suivre une formation pour pouvoir
utiliser le taser et ils ont
l'obligation de le tester sur eux mêmes
comme l'a fait ce policier municipal en
attendant que la loi lui permettent de
se servir data ça vous fait plier crispé
tous vos muscles donc vous tomber au sol
et puis bon c'est quand même une douleur
assez forte en 5 secondes et
et après effectivement pour se mettre
dans la peau d'un interpellé comme vous
voulez pas en avoir une deuxième
décharge vous donnez vos poignets sans
difficulté mais policiers municipaux
tout en restant protéger comme ils le
sont avec le beretta n'occasionneront
aucun dommage à l'individu qui pourront
comme ça saisie remporté au commissariat
de police
sans qu'il ait des trous dans la peau
pourtant aux états unis en six ans 152
personnes sont mortes quelques heures ou
quelques jours après avoir été touché
par un taser mais aucune enquête
médicale n'a pu prouver que le décès
était lié cette arme électrique ou les
décès pour lesquels a été incriminé à un
moment donné les effets électrique par
exemple sur des piles cardiaque sur des
pacemakers ou bien des risques de
fibrillation qui sont un trouble du
rythme cardiaque
tout ça n'a jamais été prouvée
médicalement en revanche le taser
pourrait connaître des défaillances en
septembre dernier des policiers de la
bac interviennent dans un restaurant
parisien pour maîtriser une forcenée sur
elle le taser n'aura aucun effet il
n'est pas tombé
il y avait du monde
entre la décharge des trains et donc
d'une
si l'on est
jean pierre bel
c'est pas le cas et on va commencer à
courir
pardon
mais c'est faux
finalement pour sauver son coéquipier le
fonctionnaire a dû tirer sur la forcenée
et l'a blessé grièvement une défaillance
qui pousse les policiers a accepté le
taser à la seule condition de pouvoir
également conserver leur arme à feu